and a lot of women leave these
situations thinking the grass is greener
on the other side they think that all
the men that give them attention
actually want to date them when really
they just want you for a weekend they
don't want you long term I cannot stress
this enough the majority of single
mothers do not remarry and if they
remarry they are more likely to divorce
than they are to stay with their partner
15% roughly of single moms get remarried
22% get a to live with them meaning 60%
the overwhelming majority do not remarry
and why does every single mother think
that she is special every child you have
with a man decreases your sexual market
value by at least a point at least it
doesn't matter how good-looking you are
you have two three kids with another guy
you're done don't expect to remarry